nope didn't happen I'm gonna go fill my
review lights out as a new horror film
directed by David F Sandberg based off
of his short film that made the rounds
on Facebook and YouTube and impressed a
lot of people myself included that as a
creepy-ass short check out some time to
get a chance so we have a really
dysfunctional family a mother a daughter
and a son and all three of them are
visited by this strange woman that can
only appear when it's dark if you're in
the light you're safe but the second
those lights turn off yeah you're
screwed
it's being marketed heavily as a horror
film and it definitely is it's
definitely a scare fest but it's also a
drama about this family the mother has
lost your mind really and she's talking
to someone in her room which is really
scaring the Son and the daughter who
since moved out as well as her boyfriend
and all three of them have to converge
to try to figure out how to deal with
this situation that's happening with her
family and there's a weird creature that
comes for them in the dark so this
horror film has more going for it even
though it has a very short runtime than
most horror films that are out today I
was really pleasantly surprised with
this movie it is an effective scary film
it uses what could be considered a
gimmick constantly but what keeps it
fresh is that the filmmaker finds ways
to continuously make it seem new or do
fun or different things with it it's
really well shot the suspense is well
generated and what could be considered
by some just a jump-scare movie actually
become something rather beautiful
towards the end and I was really
surprised by this movie the performances
are also all uniformly really good Maria
Bello is fantastic as the crazy mother
Teresa Palmer sometimes has that deer in
the headlights look a lot of why huh and
you could dissect that as a problem but
I don't really think it's necessary
because her character is very much so a
deer in the headlights she has no idea
what's going on with her family and now
there's this weird thing haunting them
in the night and so yeah I guess most of
us would also have a bit of a deer in
the headlights look
also Alexander deeper SIA as the
boyfriend sorry if I screwed up his name
but he was surprisingly really good in
this film usually the boyfriend
character in the movie or the throwaway
girlfriend character is just that a
throwaway character
but he had a lot to do and he was
resourceful and that's something I also
liked about the characters in this movie
they weren't complete idiots whenever
got real they were actually
resourceful they did things that I was
like see okay good that's why you're
still alive that's why you're not dead
and that can be attributed to strong
writing this movie actually has
characters the people in this movie are
not just bodies to eventually be killed
in some horrific way by some creature
they are actually characters they have
lives they have problems these are real
people inhabiting this horror movie and
a lot of the drama is centered around
this young boy and who's going to take
care of him the mother or the daughter
the kid in this movie
Gabriel Bateman is fantastic I was
really impressed with this performance
really strong child performance and I
can't wait to see what else you can do
there's also a fun mystery yarn woven
throughout the script which I really
appreciated you don't get enough good
mysteries anymore and I like the fact
this movie actually had a compelling one
which brings me to my issues with the
movie sometimes that mystery well
compelling doesn't really give you the
answers you need to make sense of some
things
no spoilers of course but there are
times in this movie where it breaks its
own rules noises are heard in places
where the lights are on
characters open doors where they heard
noises and all the lights are on that
area and you're thinking to yourself how
did that happen if she can only maneuver
through the darkness also what was
disappointing to me was the eventual
look of this creature I actually found
it far more disturbing and effective in
the short film than in the feature film
in this film it was just that typical
like yeah yeah like you know the creepy
old deformed lady just going like this
that's in like every horror film it was
a lot more effective in the short and
I'm surprised with all the budget they
had that they couldn't make the look of
this creature better but as a quick fun
summer horror film this film delivered
it had good performances good moments of
suspense and a surprising amount of
character depth that I didn't expect in
a movie like this I'm gonna give lights
out a b-plus check this one out guys you
know I'm a big fan of scary movies and
whenever there's an actual good one out
in theaters it's to be celebrated
because man there's a lot of bad ones
also I want to give a big thank you and
shout out to the big bad toy store they
sent me that badass try gun Vash the
Stampede figure as well as Christian
Bale in Batman
ends and I have held it and touched it
and rubbed it and I'm going to stop
talking now
I left a link for them in the
description below if you're a collector
like myself definitely check out that
store they have a lot of awesome stuff
really really cool stuff especially for
movie fans which I know most of you are
guys thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck my nice